young people nobody want to be like Ella
moss what's your advice with it
I think that probably they shouldn't
want to be you I think it sounds better
than it is okay so how do you do it how
do you just not rely on wishful thinking
and hope as a strategy I mean even three
ways to do it
rise and shine
it's in spresso time what's up believe
nation it's Evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference in the world
so let's start your day off right grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
don't rely on wishful thinking over to
you Elon Musk young people nobody want
to be like Ella Moss what's your advice
on it I think that probably they
shouldn't want to be hey you I think it
sounds better than it is okay yeah it's
not as much fun being me as you'd think
I don't know you don't think so yeah
this definitely it could be worse for
sure but it's I'm not sure I want to be
me
but you know I think advice I mean if
you want to make progress and things I
think the best analytical framework for
us and in future is physics
I'd recommend studying the the thinking
process around physics like not just not
the equations I mean the equations
certainly they're helpful but the the
way of thinking in physics is the that's
the best framework for understanding
things that are counterintuitive and an
you know always taking the position that
you are some degree wrong and your goal
is to be less wrong over time one of the
biggest mistakes people generally make
and I'm guilty of a two is wishful
thinking you know like you want
something to be true even if it isn't
true and so you ignore other things that
you ignore the real truth because of
what you want to be true this is a very
difficult trap to avoid and like I said
certainly one that I find myself in
having problems with but if you just
take that approach of your oyster some
degree wrong and your goal is to be less
wrong and and solicit critical feedback
particularly from friends like friends
particularly friends if somebody loves
you they want the best for you
they don't want to tell you the bad
thing so you have to ask them okay you
know it's it really I really do want to
know and then they'll tell you I think
hope is badly needed for entrepreneurs
but hope is a terrible strategy you need
to be optimistic about where you're
going what you can accomplish the the
big world-changing things that you're
gonna do but just to expect it to happen
and not recognize the truths the faults
the holes is a blind spot I just came
back from an event in California a big
YouTube event and it was meeting was one
of the three guys in the YouTube space
that I really respect look up to listen
to advice from and I sat down with him
over a meal and I said listen tear my
channel apart I want you to be harsh I
want you to be brutal
I'm hoping that he tells me I'm stupid
like it's help tell me I'm stupid tell
me I'm missing these huge holes in my
YouTube strategy because that's great if
you can point out why I'm wrong when I'm
feeling it allows me to do so much
better if he says you know what your
thumbnails suck or your title soccer you
really should be doing playlists or you
should be tagging better whatever the
thing is if you can give me something
that points out just how massive a
mistake I'm making it's amazing that's
what I want to hear that's what will
serve me to go on and do better and so I
think understanding that you need to
know where the holes are so you can
address them instead of pretending like
there's no hole in your boat and can you
continue on paddle lanes like no there's
a hole we got to fix that hole and we're
gonna keep on paddling it's not only
being realistic and only being truthful
all the time because you need a little
bit of the optimism you need to have
that blind belief that something is
gonna happen you have to create a world
that doesn't exist but to never consider
the downside to never think about the
holes and how to plug them I think is a
weak point for a lot of entrepreneurs
okay so how do you do it how do you just
not rely on wishful thinking and hope as
a strategy I mean even three ways to do
it
number one is have a mission you have to
have a big mission that excites you that
you're driving towards that you get up
every morning you want to do I want to
solve the world's biggest problem
untapped human potential I think people
are doing the wrong thing a lot in their
lives I think people have Michael Jordan
level talent it's something and they're
not doing it and they know they're
destined for something bigger and
they're stuck in a job that they hate I
hate that I want to solve that I want
you to recognize a talent the insane
talent that you have and to believe in
it to make something amazing happen for
yourself your family your community the
world I think you have that ability and
it's my mission to pull that out I am
forever insanely optimistic about it I
bet on team human all day long
I bet on each individual one of you guys
you have that ability you will not
convince me otherwise
I think you were a genius I think you
can do amazing things and having that
mission for your business why you do the
thing that you do has to be a shining
light because starting the business is
so dark has so many negative periods of
so much pain that you have to go through
that you have to have something that is
pushing you forward
number two is be stubborn on the why but
flexible on the how this is what is so
important and what a lot of
entrepreneurs fail to understand they
y-you know what you want you have your
mission great that's amazing that's
gonna drive you every day but don't get
so stubborn on how to get there so many
people feel like they have the perfect
plane and that's the plan it's gonna
help them get to their mission that's
what's gonna help us get the mission
accomplished but you're probably wrong
you're just wrong and that's okay
almost no business when they started
what their plan was ended up being the
plan that made them ultra successful
they pivoted they changed multiple times
and so it doesn't matter expect to
change your plan will likely not work
but that's okay doesn't mean don't plan
you plan to the best of your
capabilities you execute against that
plan and then when changes happen you
adjust that's part of the game you will
never figure out all of the variables
sitting on your couch at home trying to
create the perfect plan and so you are
super stubborn this is why I'm doing it
this is this is why I'm doing this thing
the what is super important but how you
get there doesn't matter this is a
tangible example I want to solve the
world's biggest problem how do I do it I
don't care I'm doing YouTube because I
think that's the best way to be able to
do it I think it's the best combination
of my skills and where there is an
audience to be able to influence to
really influence a lot of people right I
think that's that's why I do it
why did I write the books it's a chance
table to reach a lot more people
I don't do one-on-one consulting I don't
think it's a chance to fulfill my
mission I don't think that how helps me
get to where I want to go but if
youtube's relevance dies down and
something else picks up I'm gonna go do
that thing I'm not attached to YouTube I
don't need to do this for the rest of my
life I'm gonna be trying to accomplish
my mission for the rest of my life but I
know that the hell will change where
people will get so obsessed about the
how they end up locking themselves in
one because the how we'll have to change
because the market will change because
consumers are going somewhere else the
way the world's changing so much changes
in a couple years in a year in six
months that to think that you know where
the world's going to be in five years
for your five-year plan is ridiculous
and to when you lock yourself into doing
the same thing over and over and over
again you get bored there's so many
entrepreneurs who get bored they get
bored of doing the same thing day in day
out
it's exciting at the beginning you get
to create your own life your own plan
that's why you left a company to go do
your own thing but I guarantee you if
you are
updating if you want to change if you
are not adding variety as a creative
entrepreneur you will get bored and so
you need to be stubborn about the why
and what you want to accomplish but
ultra flexible and how you get there
having no ego attached to how you
actually accomplish that mission and
number three is ask the little man the
little man is a person who's the hater
is the person who hates on your ideas
who tells you why it's not going to work
out points out all the holes the little
man is dangerous at the beginning
because if you don't have any confidence
in yourself if you're not secure in
yourself and your mission then when
somebody throws crap all over it you
might not want to do it anymore you
might value their opinion their judgment
and you don't want to go off and pursue
that thing anymore if your parents tell
you it's a stupid idea your friends tell
you it's a stupid idea you may not have
the confidence to do it anymore but if
you are solid in yourself you are solid
in your mission you know why you want to
do it it's gonna happen then talking to
the little man talking to the haters
it's actually really constructive
because all of the points that they give
you as to why it's not gonna work out is
great for you to consider there was a
guy who I used to work with on some of
these videos and every time I asked his
opinion on something he would always
give me the the most negative response
he would always look for the worst in
every video that I made if I'm if I'm
highlighting Elon Musk here he'll tell
me all the reasons why it's a super
video or it's not gonna work out like
this is great because some people think
like that and by getting his negative
opinion it actually refocuses my message
to make it even stronger I have to make
sure I address those points so that
people who think that way can be shifted
as well as much as it might be weird to
have somebody who's a hater or negative
thinker or small thinker on your team
having one person like that around you
that you can ask questions do actually
can help make you stronger and make you
better just don't let it infect you and
don't let it infect the people on your
team too now I've got a really special
bonus clip that I think you're going to
enjoy but before that I want to know
what is a single best piece of advice
that you have received from a little man
the best piece of advice you've ever
gotten from a hater I want to hear from
you leave it down the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso and
enjoy the bonus clip
this prey so give me go
was three hours and 15 minutes of one
stage and I would had this great editor
who I worked with again called Steve
rosenbloom and rosenbloom and I was
sitting there scratching our heads
picking how do we get a half hour out of
this and we couldn't figure it out
because we were so close to it and it
took a studio head to come in and give
us a general note that was Sherry
Lansing she gives us this general note
and we're like we look at her and we
look at each other he said what would
she know how did she get this job you
know in 24 hours later we're going she's
right he's first to do it yeah but but
you know what that simple note that she
gave us enabled us to go from 3 hours 15
to 2 hours 48 and it just made the thing
snail oh yeah oh yeah
big deal and I do think it's interesting
how we sort of expect like my a few
months ago I got injured and I couldn't
work out for like about a week or so and
it was like why did I think that I could
go my whole life without being like why
did I think that I would never be
injured right why did I think it would I
would all it would every time I roll my
ankle it would turn out to be nothing do
you know what I mean sometimes it turns
out to be something and and and the more
we can the more we can tell ourselves
that these are realities of life the
less devastated will be when they happen
and the more quickly we can bounce back
from them do you know what I mean like
if if someone does something rude or a
you know screwed up to you and your why
did this happen this is so unfair how
could they do this to me and all you're
doing is wallowing in self-pity
you know that's precious energy that
you're not spending towards your you
know your reply towards your response or
what you're gonna do
instead if you took yourself a story
long enough you start to believe it
don't you believe it you act like I am
Tulsa what a whale out of handcuffed
lightning though Thunder in jail now you
know I'm bad over the last week I've
murdered
rock into the stone hospitalized a brick
I'm so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between eighteen and two hundred
and fifty four days of taking action for
a new habit to stick I've created a new
course called 250 for confidence or
every single day for 254 days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access